so who's excited about testing excited
yeah okay how many of you are testing
your app was absolutely is there anyone
who is not testing their apps I don't
believe you unless your apps are not
working so yeah testing Android testing
there's been a lot happening during the
past year past two years in Android
testing we've been getting better and
better this there's now a great support
in Android studio and Gradle to run your
tests
there is the Android testing support
library it's an unbundled library it's
on the unbundled from the framework you
can update it with the support library
it's always fresh that's a good thing
and one of the pieces of this is
espresso our UI testing framework which
you probably all know about since you're
all testing your apps but that's that's
the part that we're gonna concentrate on
to today so yeah so just just as a quick
recap quick intro for maybe those of you
who are listening on the livestream who
are another's personal experts yet so
this is a basic I want to discuss the
basic espresso test flow so this is an
app we've built a couple of months ago
for a code lab for an Android testing
code lab it's a simple Android it's very
simple note-taking app where you can
just you have a list of notes you can
add a note add some text save it that's
pretty much it the thing is it's a nice
nice way this app is a nice way of like
looking at tests and and explaining them
cuz UI tests seem like a very human way
to test your apps right you get the
interface you look at it as a favor
looking at your phone and what do you do
first identify some view you want to
perform actions on so in this case I
want to add a new note so I click the
fab right and then on the on the second
screen I want to type some text in save
the note and then finally verified the
note was added it's a simple thing very
very human way to test an app and how
cuz a look in code so espresso has this
you know simple really fluent API that
lets you express these kinds of tests in
an easy way in code so let's do that
quick run-through
so first of all like I said we need to
find a view and here we are looking for
a view with the ID and note it's the fab
when a special finds the view I want to
perform an action on it I want to click
on it and then on the second screen
again I'm finding views in this case the
input fields and I'm performing another
action it's type text so I'm typing text
into them
again clicking on a fab to save the note
and here in this final the last line of
code you see things are a little bit
different I don't want to do any more
actions I want to verify the result of
my tests so instead of performing an
action I'm actually doing a check I'm
trying to match if the the note that I
added if the text that I added with the
note is actually displayed on the screen
so that's the basic espresso test rate
and one nice thing about espresso is you
might notice that apart from those basic
building blocks these on view calls
these view measures and view actions and
assertions at the end there's nothing
really in between and that's the magic
of espresso this is the whole point of
using this framework espresso notice how
in the previous in the test that I
displayed we went through another
activity and back we went through three
different screens we know perform typing
we had to wait for the screens to change
and finally to display the final result
but there was no code in between to wait
for those events that's that's espresso
but when people come from different
backgrounds from the different you know
testing frameworks maybe and they try to
use this press over their apps I see a
lot of questions on Stack Overflow and
answers that kind of try to work against
that API and so let's look at like
something that people that I've seen in
answers of Stack Overflow that's not
entirely correct so instead of working
with us presto and using the the
constructs that I just discussed like
view measures people ask usually ask a
question how do I get the view how do I
get a view object to like just do things
to it to change properties and verify
things well you really shouldn't this is
like a very obscure API this is not my
- for you to use this will even this
will just not work the other thing that
is you know a little bit more dangerous
is like getting the the activity and
like finding stuff in the view hierarchy
this line of code would actually work
but it's it's not really what you want
to do I mean it will work as in it will
not throw an exception but again this is
this is working against espresso and
what question for you this is something
I've seen how many people will think
this test will actually pass No
well it will because it doesn't do
anything it just on view doesn't run any
with espresso actions it just returns a
view interaction object which you can
act upon next and you know mq actions or
do assertions this this doesn't even
look for the view in the hierarchy so
coming back at a proper espresso test
like I said this just returns the view
interaction object and only when you
actually Act them that this is where the
espresso magic starts and so in this
first part of this presentation I just
want to talk to you a little bit about
internals so that you have the knowledge
that will help you when building your
tests and you know finding all the
different scenarios and different ways
that your tests can fail so let's look
at the view interaction class this is
source code from espresso it's open
source you can go look it up you can
open it yourself you can you dig into it
I really encourage you to do it it's not
that big and you know you can it can
give you a better understanding of what
happens under the hood so when I perform
an action on the view attraction object
this method do perform this cold and the
first very important thing that happens
is it starts running everything that it
does on the main thread so these the the
test the the test method that you write
it's actually on a different thread if
we want to
work with views what work with the view
hierarchy we have to switch to the main
thread first then this is a very very
important thing
ui controller is the most important part
of espresso I would say this is an
internal craft that's an espresso I mean
yeah a class on espresso that has this
method called loop main thread on so
I'll go and this is where all the magic
happens that I mentioned before this is
the place where oh well where special
waits for your app to be idle and I will
discuss in a sec what it actually means
for your app to be idle and only then
only after espresso finds that it can
run it can actually run your action
safely when the app is not doing
anything will it actually kick off you
know traversing the view hierarchy
finding the view and matching it against
against you matter only then and then
when it finds the view of course it
performs the action and passes in the UI
controller so if you're writing any
custom actions you can use it again
instead of instead of trying to do
things without espresso so your
controller loop main thread until idle a
long name but so what it does it first
sets up conditions
it looks at async tasks in your app it
also looks at async tasks from the
support library which are use a
different thread pool so it needs to
look at both of those and then it looks
at all the unlink resources which is a
custom mechanism to tell espresso that
your app is not idle which I will
discuss in a sec it sets up all these
conditions waiting for all this team
things to be idle and then runs another
method which is loops and waits until
these conditions are met and what's
important in the end
it also looks and the main looper the
main like a looper is something
associated with your thread that has a
message queue so it basically looks in
the message queue if there are any
events that are still like pending still
preventing espresso to run safely and
there's one common misconception about
this so if I have a handler that's
attached to the main thread so I'm
posting to the main looper right if I
post a message
post a runnable that's delayed 500
millisecond
what do you think is the app idle now
after I run this line of code and who
thinks the app is idle it's not and
you're right
you must be real advanced espresso
experts since you came to this talk so
when the queue is empty so this is again
part of espresso this is part of a class
that looks at the message queue and
determines if it's safe to run so the
first condition is pretty
straightforward
if the queue is empty if there are no
events on the main thread they're
waiting to be executed then of course we
can run but then there's this other part
of the condition and what is this task
do long basically it's a task that's a
long time in the future and if you look
at another piece of code that looks at
the queue state there's there's actually
a you know constant that we came up with
when working with espresso for a long
time and testing different scenarios but
basically we found that if we look only
a test at messages in the message queue
there are up to 15 milliseconds in the
future
then this will work for many many
scenarios scenarios so just one thing to
be aware of because that's a common
misconception I've seen online so yeah
if I post something really far in the
future
espresso can run and circling back to
IMing resource so I think resource is a
pretty simple but powerful concept that
you can use if you have long-running
operations on different threads in your
app on threads that are not using async
tasks or or async task combat because
espresso can synchronize on those but if
you have some kind of network operation
or some kind of long computation
something you have to wait for until
your app is actually considered idle you
just implement this interface and again
there's a it's it looks pretty simple
but people do a lots of developers
especially in the beginning and
everyone's a beginner at some point of
course people actually do a lot of
computation or figuring out if the app
is idle in the is idle method and I
really encourage you to make it as
simple as possible this would be just
returning a boolean flag if you
as Idol or not don't call on transition
Idol in the East Idol method instead
when your app actually becomes either
way your network request finishes your
computation finishes then remember to
call on transition to Idol on the
callback that this press will supply to
you because that's really telling
espresso I'm gonna be algn I'll check
my state and maybe espresso can run now
and I just want to mention another
another powerful method on the UI
controller if you're ever writing any
custom interaction and custom actions
whenever you feel like you want to use
thread sleep because you know that
sometimes need to pass between an event
I you I want to happen
don't use thread sleep please instead
use the construct we give you an
espresso use this method it sets up a
condition it waits until the time pass
passes and then again with loop until
you get all the same guarantees about
the message queue about the app being
idle so please use those things if
you're doing more advanced stuff and
moving on in the second part I would I
just want to talk to you about tips and
various and pieces of advice that I
gathered from internal teams on Google
working with espresso hopefully it'll
help make your tests better less flaky
more maintainable so I'm gonna go one
way back through them yeah I mean do you
care about your code structure your apps
architecture your you know good quality
overall for your app probably yes what
well then why should you care about the
same for your tests and let me just show
a very very simple example if you're
still not convinced so with espresso
sometimes you need to code pretty close
to the implementation right so expect
for example if you use on data to look
for views in your adapter views in the
ListView the simplest simplest example
of this you have a ListView backed by an
adapter back by like map items and so
you write this line of code your test
passes and then you need to use it in
another test
another test and so on so you copy paste
it everywhere and then imagine you
change the adapter you change the data
that's backing your ListView you're
starting to use a cursor or whatever
else and suddenly you have to go and
change it in every test in your code
pee-wee daunting so instead just try to
abstract away any more complicated
matters any more complicated pieces of
code try to again this is very simple
you can you can you know write your own
robots or more sophisticated ways to
abstract away working with screens in
espresso but then you just need to
change one place and your tests will
pass again then one thing I want to
stress throughout this presentation
please use the available AP eyes and
classes that we give you an espresso use
them available measures we provide a lot
of matters for pretty much every view
that's in the framework for most
properties that are in the framework and
if something is missing then maybe we
emitted it maybe it should be there and
it would be nice if if you find this
kind of situation to please file a bug
with us on the same but on the other
hand we can't know everything about the
custom views you make so definitely
there are moments when you would like to
write your own matters and another
instance of that is if you find that you
are combining lots and lots of matters
for your actions maybe it's nice to ever
again abstract away under this
complexity and write a custom measure a
compound measure that does that I just
want to point out again there are
classes that will help you with that so
for the simplest matters you want to
just extend the types types if matter
they'll work only on views you don't
have to do casting
things like that and if you want to
filter out this is very similar but if
you want to filter out just certain
types of views just swap passes of
certain views use the bounded matcher
again you will not have to do the
filtering you will not have to do
casting and matches safely you will just
get the views of the type that you care
about again we use we provide counting
island resource use it if you can if you
don't need to write it right here on
many people you know try and like I said
writing customizing resources they get
tangled up in those where should I call
which which method is when I'm when I'm
an idle and so on counting I'm counting
idling resource as a very very small API
it's basically you call increment and
decrement so you call increment before
you start a long-running operation and
you call decrement when it's ended and
whenever the counter is at zero so that
means no long running operations are
running and espresso can consider it
idle so please use it if you don't have
a better reason to write your own and on
the topic of idling resources sometimes
for example when using camping guide
when you use one counting idling
resource for everything you might find
that in your app there are times when
the app is not idle for a long time and
espresso has has some same defaults for
timeouts for such
situations but if you find that your app
is not idle for a really long time and
it's actually working as intended then
you might have to adjust the I think
policies so there's an IDI for that if
you have something that's running for a
really long time and you still want the
test to run then you might have to
adjust that next next
pretty much testing basics but focus on
testing behavior not layout properties
and still a lot of developers are trying
to use espresso to tests like the pixel
perfect ness of their layouts and well
it's technically possible it will make
your tests really unmeant a tad
maintainable so if you're trying to you
know assert that a certain view is
displayed x position x and y and pixels
and then you work with different screen
sizes and so on and then your designer
comes and tells you move that to the
right you have to redo all your tests
so please don't do that but at the same
time if you really want to assert that
if you really want to check that a
certain view is displayed somewhere on
the screen relative to another view we
do provide position assertions but
they're relative they're easier to
maintain if you just need to make sure
that a button is next to a textview or
below it then you can use the position
assertions right many most there are
many small tests instead of large ones
and to explain this I like to think
about the whole app development process
as you start with you know working on
single screens on single features of
your app you start writing tests for
those single contained pieces of your
app write a single screen a single
feature then and these things during
development change a lot so you will go
and redo your tests sometimes and just
make everything work together but then
as you as your applicants you know
bigger more mature tablet stabilizes as
you're close to release things are
probably not gonna change that much
you're gonna fix small details but you
know the overall flow of the app will
not change and that's when you might
start at
longer like user flow tests but you know
just don't overdo it
again the real value is then a small
test that they test every screen every
state of your app and on the same page
last directly into desired screen state
so again when testing these you know
these self-contained screens and States
launch directly into them don't do deep
navigation before if you like want to
test an activity that's not the first
activity in your app and you need to
traverse five different screens to get
there something something can just break
along the way and then you're not
retesting the thing you want to test
you're getting errors about something
totally different totally and another
part of your code so don't do deep
navigation there's waste you can easily
achieve that so if you just override the
activity test row you can override the
get activity intent method just provide
a custom intent if you have a an
activity that gets some kind of data and
then displays a different state you can
just provide that data and the in the
intent just remember if you use this
every test in your class
will have the activity started this way
if you need some more custom fine great
fine grained control just use the three
argument constructor and if you first
passed false false as the last argument
the activity will not be launched
automatically for your tests and then in
every test you can just prepare the
intent that you want and just remember
you have to launch the activity manually
most UI tests should be as traumatic as
possible so again you want to test your
app you want to test you want to test
the screen of your app you don't want
you don't want to test and network
conditions you know you don't want to
test it this server is working you're
testing the features that you're
counting inside your app and in your UI
so make your test as traumatic as
possible there's tools that can help you
with that there's espresso intense
there's mojito for mocking remember
about dependency injection and dagger
- and basically just make sure you're
isolated from all the layers that you
don't care about because that that's not
really UI testing then is it
and speaking of espresso intense I know
if you've used it before it's a really
nice thing that we've added to espresso
it's a very small API basically it lets
you verify intents that are sent from
your app or stub the responses too
intense that's you that you send to
other applications so here in this
screen you can see in before I'm setting
up response dubbing for an intent that I
sent out to the camera app and below at
the bottom I'm just verifying that when
I click the button my app sends out the
intent I encourage you to use it to
isolate your test from you know external
applications learn how to handle
long-running animations that's been
common and problem in espresso you know
we try to synchronize on a lot of things
like said like I said on the icing test
and so on but sometimes you know
espresso just simply can't run because
something is keeps animating in the in
your UI and there's two types of
animations I want to call out
specifically so on the left you can see
oh it's not animating this case all
right side meaning now let's say you
have some kind of drawable it's your own
it's your own animation you created it
you control it it's it's all up to you
if it's wrong runs or and or not and
under on the other hand you have
animations that are kind of embedded in
the framework right so for example a
progress bar is something you don't
really control it's just a system widget
it animates and there's not much you can
do about it and there's a way to
actually deal with the animations that
you control so for running espresso
anyway we tell you to disable animations
in this
so system-wide we disable the layout
animations transitions and so on and you
can actually leverage that setting and
read in your applications code and
decide if if the animations are disabled
maybe I should also disable my own
animations because read that's what the
user said when they when they adjusted
the setting right so it's the right
thing to do anyway and on the other hand
like I said some things like the
progress bar are not very easy to to
work with so you have you will just have
to find other ways like maybe having a
separate flavor for your test when the
drawable for that progress bar is just
not animated there's some tools that can
help so for example in developer tools
you can switch a setting called show
surface updates this might help you
identify some of those animations that
you were not aware of but are somewhere
in your UI and you know keep posting
events that keep espresso from running
and next how to handle test failures so
your test will fail sometimes and you
know it's obviously not intended but
maybe that maybe the test is wrong maybe
you need to write in some other way so
the good thing is espresso aims to tell
you exactly what what went wrong in
tests and how to fix it so we have
really descriptive error messages we
provide a message that tells you what
went wrong and moreover we provide a
dump of the view hierarchy so you can
look at the exact views and their
properties and maybe find the culprit
but if that's not enough it's very easy
to implement your own failure handler
you can you know you can attach your own
handler and just log out more data if
you have if you have some information
that you think would be useful you can
just add it to the to the log one very
interesting use of that that I've seen
online is someone said that espresso was
actually giving me giving him too much
data about the view hierarchy for a very
very complex screen and so he created a
failure
they actually made the logs smaller to
only concentrate on the parts that they
care about it's interesting use and then
there's more development the developer
tools that can help you with debugging
so you can enable showing touches
pointer location layout bounds though
basically lets you inspect better what's
happening on the screen one espresso
runs and also use the fire key viewer if
you just want to interactively explore
the fire caves for example find out the
IDS of views or their relative positions
in the view hierarchy there's one more
setting and not in developer tools but
in accessibility so on some devices that
are really slow and or some emulators
especially the older ones single taps
are not registered correctly I mean
single taps coming from espresso I don't
want to go into details but we read try
to hide away the complexity of actually
simulating a tap in espresso but a tap
every tab is actually into actions write
down an app and and if if a device is
really slow if it's bogged down by some
kind of background operations or the
system is just not keeping up these two
operations can happen too far apart and
then the system thinks it's a long press
so basically if you change the delay too
long that might help the situation and
finally enable testing for accessibility
issues so that's something many
developers still don't think about sadly
but really you want to make sure that
your applications are accessible to all
people who want to use them and espresso
gives you a very easy way just enable
the accessibility validator
it's a very easy way to start testing
for very common accessibility issues so
please enable that and fix your apps fix
your views to make sure the app can be
used by anyone and what's next I really
encourage you to look at the special
documentation there's a section called
invest espresso or advanced samples
something like that and you will see a
lots and lots of more tips and tricks on
how to use this presto how to use them
more you know unknown api's of espresso
do check out the Android test
in code lab it's not only about espresso
it's also about how to structure your
app to be more testable it gives a great
overview of all the of all the testing
offerings that we have finally we have
greatest testing samples we have a
testing blueprint and like I said before
remember that espresso is open-source so
if you find any place where we're you
know it's not working the best it could
if we're missing some kind of measures
if there's a source of flakiness for
your tests that we were not aware of
file bugs are better yet file a pull
requests and help us make it even better